foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
foreign
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Rhonda Santos I just launched a clip
of Rhonda Santos and [__] ass [__]
uh as you know Nikki Haley announced uh
her her run to lose the Republican
nomination for president of the United
States this morning
um she is going to lose that bout
uh very very quickly as well frankly
she's already lost and I described to
you weeks ago when it was announced that
she was going to announce today she had
already lost
and I've been saying prior to that that
Ron DeSantis is not going to run for
president in this cycle as long as
Donald Trump is in the race not gonna do
it and and he clearly has lived up to my
promise to you this morning uh as he is
a [__] ass [__] in front of reporters
and he Giggles off how Donald Trump is
calling him a pedophile and will
absolutely destroy him and burn him down
to the ground and piss on his ashes the
same way Nikki Haley is about the feel
the Thunder
it's gonna happen now I watched a a clip
this morning now the the name of the
show today is balloonatics distracting
Americans from real issues because
there's a lot of issues going on right
now and listen the [__] balloons and
UFOs and whatever the hell they're
shooting down it's not the issue and
United States senators
Hamming a [__] fit about uh balloons
in the sky are you unidentified flying
objects in the military shooting them
down they've already explained this time
and time again DOD has explained it the
Administration has explained it they
don't know what these [__] things are
they have not collected them and if
you're out there talking about [__]
balloons you're getting distracted from
the United States House of
Representatives that is controlled by
real America versus Nazis and also
you're gonna get distracted by the 2024
race that the Cheeto dust q and honor
will be their nominee he will be their
nominee and now is the time right now is
the time today's the day to start
driving those wedges in between Nikki
Haley Rhonda Santos and Donald Trump
today is the day right today and that's
why you are here with me
on today Tuesday taco Tuesday Texas ball
Tuesday here on the Tony Michaels
podcast noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific for two full hours because you
know I'm not gonna BS you about balloons
or talk about how Nikki Haley is the
most biggest hypocrite ever who gives a
[__] they're all hypocrites
every [__] Republican if they got an
R next to their name they're lying sacks
of [__] I don't know how many times I
have to explain this
Santos is not an outlier
Nikki Haley is gonna Gaslight and lie to
people to try to get the nomination just
like Donald Trump just like Ron desantos
they all lie every last [__] one of
them all of them
don't take any of them off the list
that's not unique what you must do in
your National narrative in your National
messaging is pit them against each other
and we have a we have a grand
opportunity here today to pit Rhonda
Santos Nikki Haley and Donald Trump in a
[__] cage match and give them give
them fatality weapons and let them fight
it out in the political ring today today
is the day that's today not [__]
balloons not to mention not to mention
that these [__] lying sacks of [__]
won't do anything about the problem with
gun violence in this country as three
more are dead and five are injured at
Michigan State University oh we're going
to talk about that [__] today too
because that balloon attacks are trying
to distract you from that
that they can't do a [__] thing
to protect Americans from ourselves it's
[__] ridiculous and really protect us
from the NRA and the gun manufacturers
that's what it boils down to folks
but Nikki Haley announces her loss today
in the Republican primary uh she
announces she's going to lose in the
Republican primary I don't even know if
she'll make it to May
like literally she's it's done
it's done because all the big donors
want Ron desantos to get his ass spanked
they all want him he's reasonable
he's a reasonable fascist
he is he has measured measured fascism
as opposed to wild crazy q and on
conspiracy theories like the Cheeto dust
q and honor down at Mar-A-Lago who is
damn near about to be indicted I don't
know if you're paying attention but Mike
Pence is trying his damnedest not to
flip on Donald Trump trying his
damnedest
not to have legal liability here because
Mike Pence knows when he does get that
subpoena which he will
he will not be able to avoid the
subpoena it is a criminal investigation
he is [__] [__] [__] and he has no
protection whatsoever
not I mean other than distracting and
timing
and again they're just trying to put off
the indictment of Donald Trump as long
as they possibly can so we the people
don't drive wedges between them
but we can do that now with our national
narrative International messaging I I
went after pod Saves America this
morning on Twitter some people notice I
don't give a [__] you know I don't give
a [__] I'm I everyone's like oh Tony why
do you go after tyt and David Pacman
they're on the left and they go after
Democrat I'm going after the left
today the stupid [__] narrative is is
that Nikki Haley is the biggest
hypocrite in politics he had no [__] no
[__] Sherlock
when the [__] when the [__] did you get
a clue about that that's not how you
form a national narrative you know what
you want to do you know what you want to
do you want to prod
Donald Trump into destroying Nikki Haley
and terrifying Ron desantos that [__]
ass [__]
to consider and not consider getting in
this race make hard decisions
these are things that they must do folks
their electorate could be broke in half
and I I don't know if you realize this
but we are now in the throes of the 2024
election cycle which is [__] stupid
but that's where we're at
and the election cycle that we're in is
the Republican primary
remember this
these are Republicans fighting
Republicans and we should encourage it
at every single moment at every single
pass we shouldn't be destroying Nikki
Haley hell we should be propping her up
so Donald Trump can knock her down
if you follow me do you find you
understand why these politics and why
this messaging and narrative is so
important
it's not it's not only that you have to
tell the American people that Nikki
Haley is a hypocrite
you have to describe to Trump you have
to show him the way to destroy her
because he's going to
oh he's going to
and if if you haven't watched this clip
of Ron DeSantis
hahaha
oh poor desantos
Rhonda Santos this morning when he was
asked
um does he plan to follow suit of Nikki
Haley's announcement to run president
oh my God he looks terrified absolutely
terrified
like he's the softball on a little
t-ball tee
like someone like Trump is gonna just
[__] crush him out of the park
because I mean why would Ron desantos
announce at this point I've described
this several times why would he what the
[__] is the advantage to him why
wouldn't he let Trump spend his energy
destroying Nikki Haley at this point
Nikki Haley is Rhonda Santos
it it's really
his prolonged announcement here if he
does which I don't think he will ever
announce as long as Donald Trump is
still walking around and breathing
especially if especially if Trump gets a
hold of his Twitter account again
if Trump starts tweeting again oh Ron
desantos no [__] way no [__] way
is that guy getting in the race
you think about this what in the [__] do
you think Ron desantos could say
what in the [__] do you think he would
he could say to get Maga to turn against
Trump think about that first we've been
trying this for [__] six years folks
trying and trying and trying to break up
his support
our damnedest
mocking them
telling them the truth the truth coming
to fruition
time and time again this [__] is
The Biggest Loser on the planet and they
still won't tear away from him because
it's a cult
but it's not Ronda Santos cult it's
[__] Trump's cult
you think Rhonda Santos is just gonna
say some magic words and get his and get
Trump's support to turn to him get the
[__] out of here with that [__]
Ronda Santos might be good at deluding
people but he's not that [__] good
he's not there he's actually a coward
and that's why he won't get in the race
and that's why Trump can fend him off
I mean I'll give it to Nikki Haley
I'll give it to her she is about to
destroy whatever political aspiration
she had for a senate seat
a a a a a cabinet seat
again as a Cabinet member well she was
hey you win ambassador
especially a vice presidential run or a
presidential run she is absolutely going
to toss that up and throw it in the
trash
just to experiment what rather Donald
Trump actually has
the delusional support of his [__]
death cult the real America First Nazis
no
well I mean I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
happy to see it I am Barry very happy to
see it
tell you one thing I'm not happy to see
is more [__] dead bodies stacked up
more dead gun carcasses stacked up
three students three students
three of them
dead
because Republicans are terrified of gun
manufacturers and the gun lobby the NRA
just dead
human beings American citizens
children going to college
dead
because we the people won't elect
[__] that will do something
about this [__]
and don't come at me with oh well both
parties have to get the [__] out of here
with that nonsense
you are a bunch of [__] boneheads if
you think both sides are the same on
guns you are some dumb [__]
those out you out there like oh we're
Democrats won't do anything either
you're not paying attention
to what's what's been trying to be done
in some of these blue states which
sometimes doesn't make a hell of beans
worth the difference because they can
drive to a [__] state
like Texas or Missouri or wherever the
[__] they want and buy whatever the [__]
they want and carry around whatever the
[__] they want
doesn't help
Illinois
Progressive gun laws just drive over the
board in Indiana then get whatever the
hell they want bring it right back into
the state
and you ain't getting [__] you ain't
getting [__] unless you get 60
Democratic senators I damn guarantee
that
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to get rid of the filibuster there ain't
no [__] way these [__] cowards
in the Republican Party in the Senate
are going to do a God damn thing
against a handful of families in the gun
manufacturers and the [__] gun lobby
they ain't gonna do a [__] thing
count on your children being killed just
count on it I know that's a harsh
reality maybe you should put them up in
flak jackets I don't know we got [__]
bulletproof backpacks
put teachers in flak jackets give them
[__] automatic weapons why not why
the [__] not I mean if we're gonna kill
each other let's [__] kill each other
let's do it
there's gonna come a point in this time
in this country
in the next 25 years
where you [__] gun nuts out there and
I'm talking I'm not just talking about
the Second Amendment Bros I'm talking
about anyone who likes to own guns
because folks the the the the dead on
secret is is that liberal Zone guns too
they [__] own guns too they got a
little different view of what
responsibility is and accountability is
but they own [__] guns too and if you
like your [__] guns you better start
talking about it
you better start talking about it
this new generation coming up being
terrified there were [__] students
that in in Oxford
just not more than a [__] year ago
went through a goddamn school shooting
at their [__] high school and here
they are in Michigan State and their
classmates are getting killed there too
within one year
you expect a human being to to just deal
with the fact
that Republicans won't do a goddamn
thing about guns
you expect that whole generation is
going to grow up and just go yeah you
know what they're they're probably right
we just need to die
we just need to be at risk
this morning I was talking to someone
and they said oh my God they left High
School
and they went to college they left High
School had to deal with gun violence
they went to college and had to deal I
said they'll leave college and they'll
go to the grocery store they got to deal
with gun violence don't leave the
grocery store and go to a Goddamn church
have to deal with [__] gun violence
they'll leave the church and go to a
concert have to deal with [__] gun
violence they'll have children those
children will go up to in elementary
schools and they'll have to grow up and
deal with [__] gun violence
foreign
this is America folks
the land of the free and the home of the
Dead with bullets
and semi-automatic rifles and handguns
You're Not Safe you're not [__] safe
nobody's safe nowhere
all all because all because Republicans
want to stuff the pockets of a few
handful of families and manufacture
weapons in this country
that's why
it's what it is and the gun Lobby's
there to help him because they get to
stuff their [__] Pockets too God damn
there's a lot of profit and guns I mean
a lot of [__] profit and guns holy
[__] you wouldn't even dream the amount
of profit
if you think this is about protection
you're a dumb [__] if you're out
there like oh I got my girl so I can
protect my family wee no one will [__]
with me
that's oh man the gun manufacturers and
the gun lobby loves you the most
oh my God they love you the most
spreading their lives and their
propaganda
as if you need to be protected listen I
grew up in Rural America I grew up on a
[__] Farm folks the closest [__]
neighbor I had was a quarter mile away
and we had guns and for deer hunting and
turkey hunting that's what we had them
for and that's the that's the
cold-blooded truth as we had hunting
rifles a few of them
and the reason why we never [__]
talked about protecting ourselves from
anybody
we left our [__] doors unlocked 24 we
went on vacation and didn't lock our
[__] doors because I don't even know
if we had a [__] key to the house
we left the goddamn the tractors the
equipment the [__] truck the cars all
had the [__] keys in them with the
doors unlocked those guns weren't for
[__] protection
you [__] gun lunatics out there
who think that your guns are gonna
you're gonna protect yourself and your
family with your guns you are some dumb
[__]
you are some dumb [__]
do you think those three [__] college
students what about all those kids down
in Uvalde what about the people in the
grocery store the people in the
nightclub the the people at the the
goddamn Chinese New Year
celebration
do you think do you think those people
were protected by guns Jesus Christ at
the at the goddamn Chinese New Year the
good guy without a gun stopped the bad
guy with a gun
and last night last night the [__]
shooter shot himself
the bad guy with the gun stop the bad
guy with the gun you are some dumb
[__] if you don't know it's the
guns
and in the next 25 years when this
generation
who has to deal with gun violence
because of you stupid bastards spreading
gun manufacturers in the NRA's
propaganda finally decide no we had
enough of this [__] they're gonna take
your [__] guns
it ain't going to be a president you
[__] idiots
it's gonna be an entire generation of
children who had to grow up in fear
cowering underneath their [__] desk
because you won't do a goddamn thing
you won't do your [__] jobs
Republicans and protect Americans
because you are [__] cowards your
[__] ass [__]
you think it makes you [__] tough
you think it makes you [__] tough to
allow other people with mental health
condition to just murder people and let
me let me let me preface this because
they're gonna blame this [__] on Mental
Health today oh they're already gonna
start to do this stupid [__] as if
they're going to do anything about
mental health either
listen we can't stop mental illness we
can't stop it we can do a lot to help it
we can do a lot for American the
American people and people in America
that have mental health problems we're
the richest [__] country on Earth we
can do anything we [__] want to
including run around killing each other
with guns
but if you think all mentally ill people
want to [__] murder people on a mass
scale you're a dumb son of a [__]
you don't understand how mental illness
works and you're probably a minute a
little mentally ill yourself
and this idea that you're using guns to
protect yourself from your enemies and
especially your government if you ever
if you ever say the words I get my guns
to protect myself from a tyrannical
government you're the person who don't
need gins
you don't need him we shouldn't let you
have him we shouldn't even let you near
[__] guns
I believe this next generation is going
to take away your [__] guns you gun
nuts I'm gonna have Texas Pawn today
he's got guns he's got all kinds of guns
[__] they're sitting in the cabinet
behind him right there on set
they'll come take his guns I almost bet
that Paul would almost hand him over
willingly if that generation came and
said hey Paul
we're gonna buy your guns
they're gonna do it folks they're gonna
do it it ain't gonna be a president of
the United States it's gonna be an
entire generation and one Fell Swoop
across the country going enough is
enough this is how we [__] grew up
and our children are not gonna grow up
this way
what don't you understand about the
future
what don't you get about the [__]
truth and facts
they are not going to tolerate your dumb
[__]
and make their children as unsafe as
they were
I did not grow up in a world in
elementary school where we did Mass
shooter drills I didn't
I'm almost 40 years old
I didn't we didn't have a mass shooter
[__] drill once my entire my entire
time
in elementary junior high and high
school not once or college for that
matter
not once we did uh hurricane
all right excuse me tornado
that we did tornado drills earthquake
drills fire drills
and I'm sure other students around the
world could say the same my age
but we never feared
that someone would come and mow us down
with a weapon of War
there wasn't a drill for that you know
why there wasn't a drill for that in
they passed the assault weapons banned
it [__] worked
but it hasn't been working an entire
generation is being ripped apart
creating creating more
more mental health problems in this
country
so if you want to help mental health
problems you [__] real America First
Nazis who are in the pocket and have
blood on your hands of the NRA and the
gun manufacturers Just a handful of
families folks
a handful of families in this country
manufacture the majority of these
weapons just a handful just a few people
just a couple
and you don't think an entire generation
is going to make sure
that their children
don't have to go through with I mean we
do this all the time
we do this all the time
you don't think they're going to address
this issue
so you two eight Bros out there and you
gun nuts and people who own guns and
want to own guns especially you [__]
liberals who own guns
you better start speaking on this issue
you better start talking to people you
better start making them make sense
quick fast and in a hurry
time is limited time is limited to do
something
and yeah we're gonna still have [__]
stacks of bodies in the meantime stacks
of bodies children children
this is the [__] party who says save
the children now we're here to save the
children now we don't we want to protect
children from men dressed up in as women
but not protect them from [__]
weapons of war [__] that [__] and
there's way too much money in that
way too much money
and gun manufacturing not near as much
money in drag shows
so let's let's protect them from let's
protect them from someone dressed up
trying to teach them how to read
that's the real that's the real that's
the real Danger
ignore the person coming into the to the
drag show where they're trying to to
teach children how to read and mowing
down the innocent little children ah
forget about that guy that guy has a
right he has a god-given right to kill
children on a mass scale god-given right
don't be looking at me this is their
[__] logic not mine
what do you want me to do you want me to
feel sorry
I'm tired of crying over it I'm tired of
feeling sad about it to be quite honest
with you
I think the country is too
they're sick of hearing these [__]
stories over and over to 67 67 mass
shootings and 45 [__] days
we should have 67 we shouldn't even have
67 mass shootings in a decade in this
country
67 and 45 [__] days
foreign
situation but it's up to you
I I know it's a it's a [__] it's a
hard long slog here with democracy
but that's why we have to stay focused
we have to stay focused on who in the
[__] is going to run this country who
the [__] is going to be in our House of
Representatives who the [__] is going to
be in our Senate who's going to be our
Governors our Secretary of States our
state legislators all the way down to
the God damn [__] dog catcher
we have to pay attention and we have to
call these [__] fascists out for who
they are they're greedy [__] [__]
ass [__] every last one of them I
have some great news for you
I know coming off that you would think
Tony Jesus Christ you got great news I
do I promised you I made a promise
yesterday and I've kept it
we're gonna go to break here and bring
in Texas Paul into this conversation I
want to show in this video of Ron
DeSantis being a [__] ass [__] but
before I do that I want to give you I
told you yesterday I promise this week
we would get new merch and it is
delivered the Surf's Up [__]
t-shirts are ready this is one design
we're going to do several design over
the next several weeks so you guys have
some choices if you really like this
design go to
store.thetonymichaels.com that store at
the Tony michaels.com it Surfs Up
[__] now I I did M efforts on
this so that you know
it wasn't too risque
but you can go to
store.thetonymichaels.com that store at
the Tony michaels.com check out the new
design we're gonna have a
pab45 design coming we're working on it
right now we're working on another
Surf's Up [__] it'll probably
say [__] on that one so just to
get kind of give you an idea in case you
want to you know hold off I I mean you
know the merch is great support it's
great support
you support the show we get to continue
doing this every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
for two full hours and you get a you get
a great t-shirt you get a treat great
t-shirt so go to store not the Tony
michaels.com there are several colors
available go check it out Surf's Up
[__] t-shirts at store at the
Tony michaels.com also
um another announcement for the patreon
members out there I am going to make
that design every time I put a design
like this on the internet someone
[__] steals it so what I'm gonna do
and they're gonna steal it it's gonna
happen don't worry that's what the nrx4
is stealing images I don't know if you
know this or not it's for stealing
content
but what I'm going to do is I'm going to
put that file if you look at it here the
round surf set [__] I'm gonna
put that file on patreon for the patreon
members to download first so you will
get first nabs at that Surf's Up
[__] art so you can use it for
your ABI or whatever if you want to post
it on your social media whatever you
want to do with it it's yours I'm giving
it to you you can download the file I'll
do that as soon as the show is over I
will make it available to the patreon
members and don't worry if you're not on
patreon don't worry in a few days I'll
put it up on social media you'll be able
to steal it there or steal it from the
patreon member says they put it up on
their social media like I said the
internet is design I mean that's what
the internet's about stealing content I
mean
who'da known who'da known so go check
out uh patreon just go to the
tonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you can click the patreon
link there you can become a member and
be one of the first to download the art
to use it on your social media platform
um and also thank you to all the new
patreon members we're getting more and
more we're so close so close to our 100
goal thank you so much uh I I thought it
would take me much longer
and to get to 100 members over there at
the [__] fam on patreon but
um you guys you guys are the best
audience in the world I truly believe
that and even if you're not a patreon
member you are an honorary member of the
[__] family especially here if you're
every single day in the chat on YouTube
YouTube Twitter twitch simulcasting from
the Midas touch Facebook page this is
the Tony Michaels podcast and we got
Texas Paul coming your way right after
this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[__] them Buckle [__] em [__] em [__] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around through the break
video of Rhonda Santos I have [__]
[__] ass [__] oh my God what a [__]
[__] Texas ball I cannot believe lent
um people don't realize how much of a
[__] ass [__] Ronda Santos is I've
been calling him Rhonda Santas
um you know for the reason of it sounds
similar it gives a good description of
how much of a liar Ron DeSantis is but I
think Rhonda Santos is a pretty good
nickname for him what do you think
uh you're you're muted there Texas ball
you get on mute there you go sorry I do
this all the time I apologize I always
leave my mute but no but yeah you hit it
on the head Ron Sanchez is one real
fragile little [__] he really is
he is not a tough guy he cannot hand he
falls [__] apart in just about every
situation he's a temperamental little
[__] he is he is not going to do well
in the presidential campaign he's not
people I've got so many gen xers that
you know I don't know what the [__]
happened to my generation
we were the generation who said we are
not going to be our [__] parents we
are not and then half you [__]
turned into your [__] parents I don't
get it I don't get it but anyways they
all think DeSantis is their savior they
think he's going to be a great guy he's
going to be tough he's going to be no
he's a little pussy-ass [__] just like
Trump he really is
well I think he's more of a [__] ass
[__] and Trump if you want to know the
truth and I think that's a that's a
really low bar
um uh Jan Riley points out on YouTube uh
meatball Ron the sanctimonious
um yeah I guess I guess Trump's new
nickname new nickname for him is
meatball Ron did you hear that
that's that's what trumps call him as
meatball run let me tell you something
the the thing about
um Trump that he does really well and I
I don't know if anyone's noticed this or
not he does a really good job of not
giving a [__] when he destroys his
political opponents and folks his
political opponents at this point are
Republicans we are now entering the
season of a Republican primary he is
happening to run an election against
Republicans and we should encourage and
drive those wedges and encourage this
all the way seven days a week endlessly
and what oh yeah destroy them
oh yeah I you know uh I was listening to
Ben Marcellus last night talk about this
very thing he said folks you cannot wait
to the election right to get into this
we have to be doing this now
Trump wants to to Brand desantis's
meatball run Tony you're absolutely
right we need to [__] out of that we
need to grab that by both hands and yank
it and flip his ass over and
[__] branded right on his ass cheek
meatball Ron you know I mean just use
everything they use against each other
just jam it right up their butts man we
really do well I mean and I'm not just
talking about in like threads on social
media you need to be saying this stuff
in front of your especially your trumped
up family what do you got there what's
on your coffee cup what's inside my this
is how much Tony
you know like we got cut off the other
day when we were on the phone because I
had to run but but you know you have no
idea how much how do you calling you
calling and whisper sweet nothings into
my ear don't be dumb people man
I'm telling you Tony
this is how much I love you my brother
and and you folks in the audience this
is how much I love you my beautiful wife
to me walked up this morning handed me a
cup that said roses are red violets are
blue I want tacos and queso too handing
me a full cup of coffee
in this mug but then but then
reaches around from behind her back she
had a whole gallon size of Del Monte
pudding
in the can looks at me
gives me the wink and shuts my door
and I'm still here with you people what
the hell man I love it I truly love you
people I really do well it's a great
time when you're here and today is
Valentine's Day I don't want to I don't
want to miss that Miss Texas falls in
the chat here
um she says uh let's see if I can pull
it up there it is oh she's laughing at
you she's laughing at you from the other
room yeah in the chat yeah
well she loves your show man today is
Valentine's Day and uh you know I I
don't know I've been married for a long
time and um I always felt like
Valentine's Day was for dating people
and it's kind of how we felt we don't
like to go out on Valentine's night
because you can't get a seat at a
restaurant all these people are trying
to all go to a restaurant I don't know I
just never never really did the
Valentine's Day but I got a little um
surprise my daughter I'm gonna go pick
her up from school today so I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go get her a box of chocolates
and some flowers
and surprise her at school so she really
you know that that that little one and
boy she she is the the light of my life
that little one so I think that's what
I'm that's how I'm gonna celebrate
Valentine's Day you you and you and and
my wife are are the same she's like oh
she literally this is a quote the only
people that should be making money off
Valentine's Day or adult stores
I love all this love [__] I do man I
don't give a damn you've been married 20
30 years you need to go you need to look
at that woman you need to look at that
man you need to grab him by the face and
give him a big old kiss and say baby you
still light up my life I mean you really
got to do it man this is the day happy
sumbitch
uh so I'm gonna play pirate later some
people are talking about sex toys in the
chat boy we really got off the market
our bad start dude I'm gonna play pirate
later you know what pirate is
that's what you run into with your
spouse and say I surrender that booty
oh my god oh Valentine's Day with Texas
Paul Jesus Christ well you know um back
to uh not not to get too much on sex
toys but uh meatball meat dog meatball
Rhonda Santos here I want to show you
this clip it's not very long it doesn't
need to be very long to show you that
Ron is terrified
absolutely 100 terrified of trump uh the
reporter asked the question here uh
because Nikki Haley announced a run
which we'll talk about here in a second
but it's more important that we draw
wedges between these [__] no
exactly then know exactly who and why
they're they're running let's let's
listen to Ron
meatball Ron desantos
[Applause]
anybody else I don't know if you've ever
seen the look of fear of someone on
someone's face but this little lamp here
and this look
oh I don't know I don't know the the
Mussolini Jesus would probably break me
in half if I did I mean really he's
he's he's only giving us the tale that
he's terrified of trump here
well you can tell by the way he acts man
I mean his reaction to Disney's reaction
this some [__] is dirty and he's got
[__] in his closet and and like you said
I mean you nailed it Tony Trump has no
safeguards no rails no no there's no
line he will not cross and and the Santa
should be scared the Santa should be
scared because I I guarantee you if he's
got a skeleton in the closet Trump will
pull it out and and and and you know not
just hold it up but man he'll have sex
with that damn thing on Primetime TV
just to make sure everybody takes a look
at it I mean he is really and he's good
at garnering attention so yeah he's
going to hold up everything that's
negative about Rhonda santis and he's
going to hold it up for us and he's
going to make a spectacle out of it and
we need to encourage the [__] out of him
we really do you know you know uh Gabe
Sanchez is here in the background and
Gabe I don't know if you just heard what
happened but um Texas Paul just alleged
that if there's a skeleton in meatball
Rhonda Santos is closet that he will
pull it out and he will have sex with it
um if he has to to win and how
appropriate on a Valentine's Day than to
talk about sex toys and sex with
skeletons and meatball Rhonda Santos I
mean just you know you know the love is
everywhere
Santa's going oh I
I'm running I can't no I haven't even
seen that oh well okay let's go the last
the last I know is when he was having a
difficult time on stage during the
governor debates and he's like well it's
I'm you know right because because
Charlie Chris said Hey Ron tell the
audience yeah if you win if you win this
governorship will you run will you stay
Governor or will you run for president
and he couldn't answer and he said he
can't answer because he won't answer
because he doesn't want to answer here
here is a reporter this morning at I
don't know what kind of of a low low
testosterone event this is uh little
dick energy uh press conference this is
but he's asked uh meatball is asked
rather
meatball oh my God meatball is ask
rather that's a great nickname by the
way meatballs asked rather uh he's gonna
get in now that Nikki Haley's in punch
unique presidential Run State you plan
on following suit wouldn't you like to
know
yeah that's why they asked
I don't know if you again I said earlier
I don't know if you've seen a look of
fear before him but then
oh yeah uh wouldn't you like to know
oh here is um here's Fox News here's
John Kennedy you know John Kennedy is
there used to be a cartoon on Looney
Tunes and there's a real big chicken you
remember what a Foghorn Leghorn yeah
yeah are we talking about we're talking
about fake fake accent John Kennedy yeah
that guy yeah yeah yeah okay who used to
be a Democrat Harvard John right Harvard
John that likes to say I say I'll say
this is the way I like to talk when the
cameras pointed at me you know yeah well
here is here is um here is John
Kennedy's response to Nikki Haley
announcing today I'm sure I haven't
watched this but I'm sure it's uh it's
fantastic and John Kennedy shows how
much he's scared of trump in this moment
watch
Nikki Haley and I'm running for
president does she have your vote
well I I don't know Governor Hanley I've
met her I think she's going he didn't
know her he's met her right
I'll do I do I do I do say I do declare
I have never met her in my life I've
seen her on the television and Nicki
Haley is that I
I look I'm getting another call right
now gotta go
oh my God it it is [__] ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous that they ABS now
I'm not done with this clip by the way
I'm not I'm not can you turn the volume
up on the clip uh I got it up as high as
I can get it okay yeah that's just
that's yeah it's Clips what are you
gonna do it's on Twitter but it is funny
I mean it does show you the fact that
the instant responsive like will you get
the vote he's like well I I
I don't know that person so I can't put
my uh I I don't have I don't have any
skin in this game here
and how damn disingenuous is that I
don't know Nikki Haley my ass those two
have spent so much damn time together I
mean
he is just a [__] John Kennedy is a
[__]
any Sunshine wait a second John Kennedy
he's a [__] ass [__] is what he is
he's a [__] ass [__] and he's
terrified that if he goes on Fox News
and says anything just in the slightest
hint in supporting Nikki Haley that
today on true social Donald Trump will
destroy John Kennedy destroy him and
burn him to the ground and piss on his
[__] action and that's why he's doing
this this ain't got nothing to do but
they know they know Trump is going to be
the nominee as long as that fat [__] is
breathing
it doesn't matter indicted or not
indicted he's gonna be their nominee
that's what they have to live with they
[__] made this bed they have to sleep
in it let's see what he says about
sleeping around with Trump and then
trying to talk about Nikki Haley here
they have to um
to do a little more than just say I'm
young
um I think competition makes all of us
better I think you'll see other people
get in the race but they need to talk
straight up to the American people uh
tell them what they believe don't lie
wait wait wait wait wait John Kennedy's
best advice to Republicans to
Republicans getting in a primary race of
Donald Trump is not lie okay yeah okay
yeah this is a great advice there you
[__] liar that's all that's all they
have though you know what else do they
got Texas ball what else do they do
besides lie not a damn thing not a damn
thing you know it used to be I did a
video on this the other day there you
the Republicans used to be an opposition
party that's what they were that's that
was their existence they didn't govern
they were our foil that's that was their
purpose in life now they're nothing
they're nothing they're freaking
Marjorie Trader green drama [__] that
all they want to do is is is just create
one [__] narrative after the other
after the other to feed their people who
are addicted to this [__] now I mean and
it doesn't end well you know that I mean
you know there's no way that that
because the the outrage machine must be
fed constantly and there just isn't
enough [__] in the world
Hey listen there's all kinds of balloons
in the sky there's balloons are shooting
down every day text Paul these balloons
are getting out of control we don't know
what these balloons are about I'm
telling you about the UFOs or aliens or
extraterrestrials or Chinese spy
balloons who knows what they are who
knows what they're collecting who knows
what virus they're gonna I mean thank
God but that's the point the inside
baseball knows that that this is they've
jumped the shark they've jumped the
shark and and they're losing their
bleeding supporters right now because
they jump to shark that's why they were
in such a tizzy about going back on the
offensive because they think that's
going to bring everybody back to them if
they can just really own us really hard
you know they think that'll put them
back into that you know stop the
bleeding but they are they have they
have completely jumped the shark people
are acting and that's the worst thing
that could possibly happen to somebody
that is just a scam artist or a con
artist or you know is for somebody to
say
that's not right for the first time
because then they're open to not
believing you you know then then that
crack is there that we can dig our
fingernails into on a daily basis where
you and I and Gabe do this on a daily
basis we just beat the [__] out of them
with their own [__]
that allows That Base to actually hear
us every once in a while and they they
really are if you look at the inside
numbers if you look at look look at the
polling that that that not not the [__]
the CNN puts out not the [__] that you
see on on the news I'm talking about
what comes into the offices of of of
house members comes into the offices of
senators
the Republicans are [__] man they are
[__]
well I couldn't agree with you more and
I I that little thin crack that you're
talking about
um because I my my goal is to fix this
[__]
um a lot of people have you know got
onto me for attacking tyt and David
packman they don't like that I'm I'm
banging them up because their
commentaries [__] trash because folks
it's garbage it's trash and it doesn't
benefit democracy it doesn't help
democracy for tyt to tell people well
you shouldn't vote because it doesn't
matter because both sides are the same
so don't vote that doesn't help
democracy and I want to call out someone
else here this morning and I'm probably
gonna get in [__] trouble for this
everyone's gonna be bitching at me
because I call out pod Saves America
[__] them I don't give a [__] I don't
give a [__] this is weak [__] ass [__]
commentary from tyt on Nikki Haley it is
I'm gonna tell you why and I'm gonna
tell you why I think so and I'm gonna
tell you why you should come here and
listen to this [__] instead of that
garbage I know I know a lot of people
are gonna [__] say you son of a [__]
you're going after the number one
[__] liberal podcast in the country I
don't give a [__] this is weak ass
commentary and this is the mistake that
that liberals that liberals made and
continue to [__] make every day when
when they are they are distracted by
certain things and not doing the thing
they should do which is politicizing the
[__] out of it and making doc again
these [__] are supposed to be
in politics they come from politics
folks now on pod save America and I'm
sorry to get on a tangent here but they
come from Politics the number one thing
they should know is this race has not a
goddamn thing to do with the general
election 2024. this is a Republican
primary this is a Republican primary and
the way that they frame this up is if
Nikki Haley is the biggest hypocrite in
the [__] Republican party is really
[__] stupid they're all Hypocrites
they're all [__] Liars what you need
to do is you need to force Republicans
like like John Kennedy to get on [__]
Fox News and have to defend that [__]
that [__] slime ball Nikki Haley
defend her or not defend her and then
pit Trump against them listen this is a
Republican primary folks this ain't got
nothing to do with Democrats but we can
push our narrative and our messaging
into their primary so let me and now I
said love you as in uh love you pod say
I didn't want too many people getting
[__] mad at me but uh I don't I don't
listen to the show to be quite honest
[__] them don't listen that trash I
don't need a list of someone else's
commentary to come up with my [__]
ideas but I said love you and you know
you take that for what it's worth it's
Valentine's Day uh but I said this you
have to put down in here Trump and Nikki
Haley learn from your mistakes now this
is this is their commentary again you
know I guess he's one of these because
it's Valentine's Day love them but this
is this is the weakest [__] framing
of Nikki Haley for Donald Trump to knock
her out of the park that I have ever
seen in my life and these guys come you
these guys come from [__] election
campaigns folks they're supposed these
are supposed to be the smartest and the
brightest in politics and politicization
in this country on our side [__] out of
here with that [__] let's listen she's
one of the uh the biggest phonies in
Republican politics and that's a pretty
crowded Lane this is someone who's
defining moment as governor was taking
down the Confederate flag from the state
capitol after the horrific shooting at
the AME Church okay we all know she took
down the [__] Flag she didn't really
mean it she was forced to politically in
that moment but here's the most
important thing and they miss it in this
whole narrative you can go watch clip I
ain't gonna play a garbage here listen
the most important thing that they're
missing is Donald Trump is going to use
that against her Donald Trump is going
to use the fact that she took down the
Confederate flag from the state house at
South Carolina against her he's gonna
defeat he's going to defend and get his
army all souped up on Confederate racism
and he he is going to air down Nikki
Haley burn her and [__] on her ashes
that is the narrative that needs to
happen that is the narrow that needs to
be projected into the country not oh
well she's a she's a listen Gabe's
engine she's the biggest hypocrite ever
and uh even though uh one of the best
things she ever did was take down the
Confederate flag at the South Carolina
and then she went on Glenn Beck show and
she said that um she loves the flag the
only reason why get the [__] out of here
with that nonsense Yelling to the
goddamn microphone would you act like
you got a microphone to talk into would
you would you please lefties liberals do
it do it stop [__] being [__] ass
[__] if we're gonna politicize
something politicize it and be proud of
it be proud that you're politicizing
something that you're gonna win [__]
elections that you're gonna make these
[__] fight each other Am I
Wrong Am I Wrong Gabe Sanchez am I wrong
no I mean we should we should 100 use
what they say against each other I mean
even the other clip where you know she
said she wouldn't run if Trump was
running you know that whole thing like
those clips where she's on Glenn Becker
she's taking down the flag or she's
saying she won't run they should all be
used as a Target to be like did you hear
what she was saying about you did you
hear what he was saying about her like
it should be used as this behind the
scenes like each person has a burn book
and the [__] is out for everyone to see
we need them to hate each I mean we know
that they do but we need them to push it
and we need to push it even further to
push the idea that it's like oh uh he
was talking about her about this and she
was talking about him about this and
they don't see eye to eye and now
they're going to fight each other and
then if we can draw a division between
the party itself
then it only helps us further the cause
of saying well none of their people can
decide who to vote for it'll split their
vote who knows maybe someone will come
over because there's like we hate this
fighting [__] you guys can't figure
out what you want I'm just gonna vote
for someone else or they won't vote they
won't or they don't vote right I mean
like they go against like well what's
the point of voting you can take the tyt
approach and say this ultimatum kind of
yeah let them do that let them do that
well yeah it should always be used that
way Texas fall um and and um you know a
lot of people are gonna knock me for
this and do you think I give a [__]
probably not now my question is this my
question is this Texas Paul is that
um these These are supposed to be
political strategists on this podcast on
this left liberal political podcast
they're the ones driving the message
they're the number one liberal podcast
in America and they're supposed to be
driving message and they don't
fundamentally understand what election
is taking place they fundamentally in
their commentary don't understand that
the target is Republican versus
Republican they act like Nikki Haley is
going to be the [__] nominee and
they're they're developing commentary as
if she she ain't gonna last three
[__] months in this race we all know
that Trump's gonna destroy her every
[__] thing every single piece of dirt
that Trump has on her In that clip or
she's when she's asked will you run for
president if he runs she's like no hell
no because he's got dirt on her he's got
[__] dirt on he's gonna expose all
that so here's my question Texas Paul am
I wrong and to think that they're they
don't fundamentally understand that this
is a republican priming that is the
election cycle that we're in
no you're not wrong [__] I made a career
of it
when I got when I'm you know I don't
mean to claim too much credit here but
when I got to [__] politics it was
nothing but [__] talking like that
it was and I came in and and Republicans
wouldn't couldn't believe it when I said
[__] you [__]
and everybody was like that's what I
wanted to say I mean I can't tell you
how many comments I get even today thank
you for saying what I wanted to say and
you get these guys I mean you're you
nailed it Tony you nailed it they sit
there and they don't fundamentally
[__] understand elections they don't
they and
don't sit there and explain Nikki Haley
[__] trash that [__] I mean she is
bad for our country we're fighting for
our side [__] that [__] I mean The
Wedge Drive here's here's what I want
yeah here's what I want liberal
commentators to do and liberal
commentary this is my goal with this
whole [__] show
um Gabe Sanchez knows this from the
first time we spoke my whole goal is to
change the direction of liberal
narrative in this country and liberal
messaging because Liberals are such
[__] [__] when it comes to
offending people stop worrying about
[__] offending people if you're
worried about offending the Republicans
and Nazis and offending other political
strategists on the right [__] them [__]
them all the way to [__] hell who
gives a [__] but Tony it's not their
fault Tony it's not their [__] fault
how long did you hear [__] that sets
your [__] hair on fire you know as
much as I absolutely adore Michelle
Obama the first time I heard when when
they go low we go high
I screamed out loud reflexively the [__]
I do
I mean the [__] I do listen I'm jumping
that ditch I step on that motherfucker's
neck and crack him with a [__]
baseball bat that's what I do you know I
I how long have liberals been told you
know well politics is not we're not
supposed to to you know be you know
what's that catch phrase I draw the
blank right now Gabe you can help me
with it uh to be disagree without being
disagreeable I got it I pulled it up
pulled it out my butt did me disagree
without being disagreeable [__] that
noise [__] that noise call that sorry
son of a [__] what he is
you know if somebody has just a
different idea that's one thing I can
argue an idea but [__] Trump is wants
to be a goddamn fascist and destroy my
country [__] that [__] don't be
nice to that [__] don't sit
there and say well Nikki Haley and
Donald Trump and let's just you know do
the [__] hands and you know [__] that
[__] I mean pardon my language I don't
mean to just go on a damn cussing tirade
for no reason it's not just gratuitous
cussing but I mean it literally [__]
those people Nikki Haley is a [__]
you bring up you there was something
that you said just a few minutes ago I
mean I totally agree I mean in a
principle in principle the idea of we go
high when when they go low we go high
right like obviously like we have a
moral High ground and we have actual
immoral compass and we have ethics other
than the Republican Party who wants to
totally just gut the Ethics Committee
but or
one thing that you said that I think was
the perfect way to explain it is
we should not be you know in pod save
America is is calling them out here is
is exactly right we should not be
explaining
Nikki Haley we should not be explaining
Ron DeSantis or Donald Trump that's
right we should be using their own words
training the clips politicizing being
dramatic [__]
leveling that [__] up to 11 like it's
like a you know off off the [__] the
the level you know the the [__]
stereo but
this is one of those things where it's
like you don't take the time like I get
the whole idea like okay you know this
is NPR and I'm Ira Glass and welcome to
another Edition of how are politics in
your life that's not what we should be
doing right if you want that you can go
get that over there if you want the full
historical analysis
but for the common person right we don't
have the time the patience or just the
the the sanity to sit through someone
explain someone who is evil and who is
bad and is trying to take away your
rights by legitimizing them by saying
well actually she took down the flag
from the state capitol but she didn't
really want to do it and this is the
reason why no [__] play it up explain
the fact that she took down the flag but
she's racist and she wants to have that
Confederate flag back up Donald Trump
wants that flag Ron DeSantis is trying
to take away these things he's trying to
erase history Nikki Haley wants to do
the same thing she didn't want to take
down those statues she didn't want to
take down the flag they all are the same
[__] monster they just have a
different face and an outfit on you know
you know what you know what we should do
our goal should be is that us explaining
a clip of Donald Trump speaking into a
microphone talking about how he hates
that Nikki Haley took down the flag in
those statues that's what we should be
doing we should goad them into that
that's how we should approach the
politics let Donald Trump and Ron
DeSantis explain why Nikki Haley isn't a
good Confederate what them explain that
[__] you you know we I don't need to
tell you that she's a [__] phony
she's a goddamn Republican for crying
out loud I don't need to explain why she
took these down and how and all that let
them let the Republican explain why
Nikki Haley isn't a good Confederate and
then we'll point out how they're how
look they're explaining they're saying
the quiet part out loud
part out loud people only remember sound
bites they remember Clips they remember
the things that you know what's sticky
that I will remember for the rest of the
day that I'll mention to my neighbor to
the person at the grocery store to to my
dog walker whoever did you hear that
this is what they said that is the thing
that we should be pushing for is the
sticky aspect like what will someone
remember you go oh well that's really
[__] up how could they do that right
that's what we should do
get extra 100 agree with you like me 100
agree with you 100 agree with you but I
go a step farther I'll be honest with
you I have no [__] shame I don't
they're gonna gerrymander Texas to the
extreme they're going to gerrymander
Florida to the extreme they already do
it they already do it they have
gerrymandered these states to the
[__] extreme Ohio prime example the
[__] map in Ohio is as partisan as it
[__] gets okay folks they're gonna do
it
I don't have any shame
why the [__] is New York not
gerrymandered to the point do you do you
realize that if we gerrymandered just
New York
to the extent that they just
gerrymandered Ohio
that there would not be Republican
control of of the legislature for a
hundred years people
[__] do it oh I I agree with you
these [__] throws make them beg
you
to do something about gerrymandering
because we win if we do it we win
a great idea
[__] that's right and you cannot hold
power in any form in the next [__]
Century because we do what you do and
that's what the way my approach to it is
don't set examples [__] hurt them
until they beg you to let them set
[__] examples that's right that's the
way I feel about it the other the other
thing too is um we should gerrymander
the [__] out of blue States and for the
next three four decades until they've
been to our will to not allow
gerrymandering at all because I know I
know that liberals in this country will
be for liberalism and Liberty and they
will bend to that will if Republicans
Bend to it
um but I think our democracy it's much
more important that we use our democracy
to save our democracy not let them use
it to destroy it um speaking of that and
and speaking of tearing down our
constitution Mike Pence is trying that
this morning there is breaking news we
all know that Mike Pence was has said
that he's going to challenge The
subpoena good luck [__]
um from Jack Smith uh special counsel
what the closet they're going to use as
a speech and debate clause because what
he's claiming is the vice president is
the president of the Senate
um the the problem is and and Mueller
she wrote points it out here oddly that
constitutional provision is inspired
English Parliament wanting production
from seditious Kings like like the thing
that you're using is not the way that
you think you're using it
um my guess is I don't know it's just my
guess here I almost bet that this is
just a stall tactic that there is no way
that the Supreme Court in no way shape
or form is going to allow because
remember the Supreme Court is a separate
branch of government folks there's no
way that that the Supreme Court is going
to allow which they did not in the
Watergate case either
um there's no way that they're going to
allow that that vice president Mike
Pence cannot be [__] subpoenaed by a
criminal investigation
I have some friends in DC right I mean
you all know that I have some friends
that are both in the government are you
threatening me right now no man that's a
good time I'm telling you every once in
a while once in a blue moon I get a
phone call that has some that did some
inside tea and I can spill this I'm
gonna let you know uh Jack Smith has
stopped calling Merrick Harlem he is not
asking for permission to do anything
anymore well technically he doesn't have
to up to a certain degree yeah but
decorum requires that he reports
especially when he's going to do
something like what this show is about
today [__] for him right especially
when you're going to do something like
subpoena the vice president you you
typically call the boss and let them
know that this is coming and this there
was no [__] phone call folks Jack
Jack Smith is on the case I'm telling
you I was outraged that nothing was
happening and I started making phone
calls and they're like look hold up put
the brakes on give it a week and sure
enough it starts spilling out that Jack
Smith is no longer
working on Merrick Garland's timetable
he's no longer giving any consideration
to any of the political [__] that's
coming out of doj he is going straight
at it and I [__] love that Mike Pence
is going to try to challenge this
because this is not a congressional
subpoena [__] this is a subpoena
issued by a judge and I don't care if
that judge was [__] Eileen Cannon
down in Florida I don't care who this
[__] judge was no judge is going to
cut their own balls off by saying you do
not have to comply
with a subpoena issued by a judge well
not only that not only that because
here's what he's essentially saying I
want folks in the audience to understand
exactly what Mike Pence's defense here
Mike Pence was the vice president of the
United States he's a member of the
executive branch what he's claiming in
this defense is that he is a member of
the legislative branch that's what he's
claiming in this because the doj is the
executive branch Mike Pence is the
executive branch that's not separation
of powers or speech and debate clause
but what Mike Pence is saying is because
he was operating as president of the
Senate he's part of the legislative
branch I doubt a hundred percent doubt
that that anyone's gonna buy that
[__] argument especially when the
evidence shows that Donald Trump was
using the the seat of the vice president
to try to overthrow our election and put
in uh um fake collectors now all the
only thing that this tells me I I to me
in my opinion my own personal opinion
and you know I have my opinions here's
what I think because Kyle Chaney has
this as well he says news Mike Pence is
planning and resisting the special
counsel's Jack Spitz Smith's subpoena uh
his reasons it violates separation of
powers after all Pence was the president
of the Senate on January 6 an officer of
Congress again I doubt that's gonna work
but again that's what essentially
they're saying but here's my personal
opinion
Mike Pence is trying to hide something
about Donald Trump and the last thing
that Mike Pence's political career needs
is for his testimony to take down Donald
Trump I mean that's that I mean we have
to remember that like whenever whenever
news comes out of Mike Pence and and
he's like oh I don't want to you know
speak ill of this person or do this it's
like dude they tried to [__] kill you
they made [__] get they they designed
they built they set up Gallows to
[__] hang you they chanted your name
hang Mike Pence and Mike Pence right now
he's like yeah well you know like I
don't I don't wanna I don't wanna ruffle
any feathers and I don't want to give
any testimony and I don't want to have
to speak ill of Donald Trump I mean
probably again it really goes back to
all these people are [__] [__] ass
[__] really goes back to the idea
that Mike Pence is most likely afraid I
mean the guy was probably afraid for his
[__] life knowing that he had to run
out down into a secure location in a in
a parking uh docking station in the
building
to avoid being killed by these by these
lunatics and now the idea that they're
like oh look we're going to subpoena you
to come test like to give a deposition
uh for this case in this this
investigation and he's like oh no no I
look man I almost died the first time
I'm not trying to die a second time and
I honestly think that's Mike Pence his
fear is not of
is not of like oh a purity or of of uh
of him him doing the right thing it's
him [__] scared that for the rest of
his [__] life these Mega lunatics are
going to chase him everywhere he goes
and us try to assassinate him I honestly
think a lot of it is is just fear right
of of his life
because these people are [__] crazy
man again they tried to [__] kill him
and he's like ah guys let's not talk
about it I don't I don't want to go I
don't wanna I don't want to discuss this
one again
well this is a failure from the get-go
though I mean if you talk about even the
legal argument behind it you know what
he's talking about there there are
protections for Congress to prevent a
president from enforcing his will on
Congress using the doj uh saying okay
you don't want to vote for I want for
what I want I'm gonna go arrest 12
members of Congress and then I've got
the votes to do whatever I want yes
there are there are legal protections
to prevent that from happening that does
not apply here I mean there is plenty of
precedent where you know members of
Congress look at Larry Craig you know
Captain wide stance you know that did
not apply to him it does not apply to
him you do not have carte blanche as a
member of Congress to commit crimes or
avoid subpoenas in in the investigation
of a crime this is a non-starter from
the start all this is intended to do is
to create a hearing for a judge to say
this doesn't apply and and and they want
to they've got a calendar laid out
saying okay the election is at this
point right if we can reach this point
then it becomes political for them to
prosecute us and the election protects
us that's that's all this is it's just
trying to create delay tactics to run
out the clock on this this is not a
legal argument that's going to stand
speaking of people who have really
shitty legal arguments
um and really shitty Valentine's poems
uh roses
is trending on Twitter and I can only
assume it's because of this [__] box Ted
Cancun Cruise still talking about the
[__] gas stoves I yeah well of course
more distraction and balloons just gas
stoves and balloons so tankers tweets
this today I've got a few that I want to
read to you that are [__] hilarious
um but this is Ted Cruz's version of a
Valentine's poem
roses are red violets are blue Biden
wants to ban gas stove and is allowing
the Chinese to surveil us too oh how
cute Ted you're so cute two things that
just are outright lies I mean you got
roses or red violets are blue some roses
aren't red he spent all week last oh
yeah just thinking of he's like him and
his wife he worked hours on this right
okay I want to show you uh I mean
typically typically in this rhyming
scheme you would red rhymes with right
but stove doesn't rhyme with yeah
I love Jason shelvig by the way I follow
him on Twitter here's one half of the
good liars here's his version
um and he quotes he he uh he tags uh Ted
here as a as a picture as a screenshot
Jason says roses are red violets are
blue
Donald Trump said your dad killed JFK
and called your wife
ugly too
okay so this is more of an example of
how the right can't comedy Gabe Sanchez
uh more than anything we've talked about
this a lot like they're the parents I
mean last week Roseanne Barr oh actually
yeah I won't even I won't even show that
date that's so [__] bad her special I
think horrible
went live this week with the Fox Nation
uh programming or whatever she put her
special on Fox News she went on to
Tucker Carlson complained about how the
left eye make fun of themselves they
can't take a joke they can't you know
there's no self-deprecating humor
meanwhile she also had this line of if
you're a person in power and you can't
take a joke right and she was
specifically talking about I'm blinking
her name right now but the woman that
worked in the Obama Administration that
she called her brother
um it was like a chimpanzee or something
like that like it was it was clearly
racist like there was no way around
because Roseanne Barr is a [__]
racist yeah and I mean remember she's
over there wearing her [__] you know
Nazi stash outfit cooking in the oven
baking cookies you know gimmick right
but last week she goes on to Tucker
Carlson to complain about how the left
canceled me they are this culture War
they wanna you know get me killed all
the stuff she goes on to do this comedy
special the only bit I needed to see was
her take the same joke the same [__]
joke from Ted Cruz which by the way like
that if you call it that yeah and I use
these of quotes joke is not a joke it
was my pronouns are kiss my ass which
we've seen we've seen Ted Cruz say
multiple times at CPAC TP USA RNC stuff
just all the stuff he's always like oh
yeah this is oh yeah
kiss my ass and it's like dude your
pronouns are [__] ass [__] okay let me
let me tell you some
and that's what we need to be doing
Master Gabe right absolutely [__] pod
save America every time that they say my
pronoun my pronouns are and make that
[__] joke we need to say your
pronouns are [__] ass [__] do you
remember do you remember a time oh a
time in our great country when Roseanne
Barr was actually funny like she was
hilarious like that show was the show on
TV Texas fall like every American
related to it if you go and you watch
some of those episodes there's episodes
of her talking about how [__] minimum
wage [__] American people how uh the
American people get screwed because they
don't get to own their labor
corporations on their labor I mean she
had a lot of real messages that
connected with Real Americans her
children were [__] degenerates and
they were having trouble which a lot of
Americans suffer from I don't know being
human just being human being [__]
broke barely making it paycheck to
paycheck got to have two jobs constantly
looking for the next dollar and then you
know that show jumped the shark when she
won the lottery right but here's and and
Roseanne Barr jumped the shark when she
got [__] filthy stinking rich and now
she's lost her mind with Q Anon but
here's the thing is that is that it is
telling that Roseanne Barr has to go on
Tucker Carlson's show and then release
her comedy special on Fox Nation and
regurgitate jokes that Ted Cruz has
written right like holy [__] how how far
you've Fallen Rose it's the same and you
know I mean I I tweeted about it last
over the weekend and it really is the
Jim Brewer Goat Boy situation oh yeah
that's right nobody he's look the guy is
not funny I don't call him I do not
confuse me he used to be yeah well
debatable come on come on I I want some
of the specials he's a talented guy he
just he's not funny anymore now he
laughs at people who died from covid he
laughs at people who get the vaccine he
laughs at people who say Hey you know my
pronouns are this or I go by this or
whatever it might be right again
personal preference my body my choice he
makes fun of it
and those are the jokes that is the
whenever if someone out there can find
me one one conservative comedian
where they're like oh this is a great
special this is a funny joke
send it to me because I would like I'm
still waiting I've asked this question
two years ago and no one's been able to
give me an actual answer everyone's like
well what about this what about that and
I'm like yeah they have they have gut
field I mean they they have they have
Greg gutfels
that show is trash too it's not funny
that's ridiculous I mean they're the
same ones that are also complaining
about oh the green M M's and they're
it's like the jokes aren't the same you
want me to show you funny let me show
you you know it's happened that it's
happened to Tim Allen Tim Allen started
out funny as [__] man and then all of a
sudden he started paying taxes and and
I'll admit our tax code our tax code
[__] [__] entertainers
are you saying are you saying the more
taxes you pay the less money you are is
that what you're saying
what I'm saying is these people get in
these people get in to [__] you know
they make it they make it and the and
the money starts rolling in and they
don't have the protections the
corporations do and all of a sudden
they're getting hammered at the same
[__] rates we are you know plain old
working people and you know suddenly
they're writing six seven figure checks
for taxes and next thing you know they
end up like Bill [__] Mar you know
who was a goddamn God to me 20 years ago
and now he's just a [__] [__] he's
gonna end up in the same with you know
Roseanne Barr Tim Allen Dennis Miller
all going to end up in the same [__]
old folks home screaming about the
Liberals they're making them eat spinach
you know I mean
you would have to have some fortitude to
defend off your republicanism if you
were getting that much taxes here I want
to show you something funny here here's
actual funny this is funny a rose of the
red violets are Brew if you attempted a
coup I'm Coming For You Happy
Valentine's Day Dad
now that that right there and you know
what's great about this account this is
not the real Jack Smith by the way for
anyone who's you know like heart is
beating and has a brain but this I think
this account has tricked several people
I think Dinesh D'Souza uh quote tweeted
this thinking this was actually
Jackson's account uh there were several
others and it's just it's just parody
and they don't even know that because
they're the parody of themselves and
that's the proof that you need to know
that these people aren't funny you're
not because you are the joke like you
are the [__] punchline like you in
real life are the [__] punch line too
yeah like Bill Maher on his show every
[__] weekend well Liberals are weak
let me show you how [__] weak
Liberals are and y'all are doing this
wrong y'all are doing that wrong and
this are [__] liberals and then we
liberals say yeah [__] you you're
canceled and he's like you're picking on
me I thought we were weak man I mean you
know [__] you you know and they they
don't realize that that [__] victim
[__] it's like Tim Allen's show right
now Last Man Standing you know that that
thing
yeah it's unreal whether it's on uh it's
still standing yeah
um but
is it on every once in a while it's kind
of funny every once in a while it's got
a little funny bit to it and then it
gets whiny and then it gets [__] and
it's not [__] funny anymore and they
want to blame us and it's like no you're
just not [__] funny Cry Baby
cry-assing [__] has no place in
[__] comedy I've never watched the
new Tim Allen Show is it like oh I'm
oppressed because I'm a white dude is
that kind of thing well they used to be
it used to be on Fox right and it was on
Fox trying to remember which one I'm
pretty sure it used to be on Fox or on
CBS which are both red States right CBS
first then he whine like a [__] yeah
yeah and then they then they got
canceled right because they're like
they're like even though because again
CBS is a red that's a it's a red Channel
what does that mean it's a red Channel
because it's owned by who it's not that
it's owned it's that you have a large
demographic of people watching from Red
States what you're saying what you're
saying is the the demographic that
normally tunes into that right like if
you were to say anything they those are
blue they cater their they cater their
their programming around Their audience
and every single show with CBS is
America's number one comedy despite what
it is they always say number one comedy
it's a it's a red Chan it's a red
channel so is Fox but yeah uh ABC NBC uh
CW those are those are blue uh type of
channels but anyway
um he got the show got canceled and
they're like all right that's it and
then Fox was like all right we're gonna
take over the rights just like the same
way that you know Brooklyn 99 got
canceled on Fox and then NBC pulled them
over into their uh networking
um just a better audience for the for
the yeah he's a better audience you know
you know they understood it they were
like oh I get the jokes right
Texas Paul brings up a good point when
somebody doesn't laugh at a joke
somebody doesn't laugh at a joke right
at least understand that you know if I'm
making a joke whether you're laughing at
me or you're laughing at the joke you're
still laughing right and that's you know
most
most comedians understand that right
like
getting a laugh is is the hardest thing
if you're laughing at me great right I
can work that and I can I can I can I
can use that as fuel to get something
else going but if comedians that are on
the conservative side right they're they
complain oh you're not laughing you
don't find it funny you're trying to
cancel me it's like write a better joke
find a better audience work on it just
well you know you don't hit 100 of the
time that doesn't mean you know you have
to [__] and moan and say that you're
the Target and you're the victim some of
the the best comedy is self-deprecating
comedy one of the Masters at this is Jim
Gaffigan I don't know if you want and
any unlike me he doesn't have to use as
many curse words
um I like to you I like to use curse
words he likes to use like food words
but it's a lot of self-deprecating
comedy and to to project that the
audience it's okay for the audience to
laugh at you because you're making jokes
about yourself that is a sign of a
comedian who is a master at his craft
really is self-deprecating consumer is
some of the is some of the is some of
the best comedy that you will find now
the reason why the right is horrible
horrible at comedy will never [__]
succeed at this for who God knows how
long here they absolutely absolutely do
not participate in any whatsoever not a
shred of self-deprecating humor because
they are the punchline they are the
parody they are the satire that's why
they suck
you nailed it with Jim Gaffigan because
Jim Gaffigan is the right he is he's
extremely conservative he's intensely
religious but his comedy is [__]
funny and I watch every special that
comes out you know why because he
doesn't [__] insult me in his shows
he's funny he he is the the comedy is
funny and the fact that he is
demographically different than me
doesn't matter because he's [__]
funny you know I mean you know the thing
is Texas ball he's not that
demographically different from you he's
a white man from a rural part of the
country who grew up in a rural part of
the country under under the rule
institution the rule white supremacy
institution he moved to the big city to
make something of himself and he saw the
errors of the institution and he likes
to point those out with self-deprecating
humor like he's a master at using
self-deprecating humor to ex to explain
and just display how [__] stupid
white institutions are like he's a
master at it and and he does it with
food a lot of times food talk he does in
food jokes he does it a lot of times and
it's masterful and and he can change
conversations at tables only because you
don't even know that the conversation
has to do with with white supremacy
institutions and I know Jim Gaffigan
isn't sitting around going man how can I
fix white supremacy but he knows it
exists and he knows how to make fun of
it through self-deprecating humor and
most of the time it's food humor and
he's a little chubby kind of humor right
like he does it masterfully and he's a
master at it um Jim Jordan is trending
Gabe can you I'm trying to sniff out why
is there a clue look for that I'll tell
you I'll throw you out another one that
I really like that that he's not quite
as deafed at it as Jim gaffkin is but
he's [__] funny is Ron White that
dude is the opposite side of the
political Spectrum from me he's up for
he he actually grew up right down the
road from me not that far about about
two hours that direction in Texas two
hours is nothing you know but he is he's
[__] funny because he's
self-deprecating humor and he doesn't
[__] on everybody I mean he has he goes
farther than Jim Gaffigan says I hear my
right wing ideas but it's not like
uh you [__] Liberals are [__] you
[__] Liberals are crazy you [__]
Liberals are there Texas fall he is a
liberal yeah I mean the guy the guy
wants the guy I
know I'll challenge you on that I'll
challenge you on that and the reason why
I challenge you on that is because is
because for one reason one reason only
and Ron White's comedy comes from a
place of leave me the [__] alone stay
the [__] out of my business mind your
own [__] business and I believe that
that is truly truly where liberalism
needs to be and needs to stick their
stake in the sand that it is not
difficult it is not hard to tell people
mind your own [__] business
because Ron go ahead go ahead you're not
arguing with me there you're you're
you're actually making the point better
than I did is that yeah he's [__]
conservative he is
but we have common ground
you know liberals believe me the [__]
alone just like conservatives do the
only difference is we live it they talk
it you know I mean
not everybody that's on the other side
politically
offends you because they're not [__]
offensive Ron White for me is a great
example I mean he he also always tests
that line you know he does but he's
[__] hilarious you know keep it funny
guys that that's it Roseanne Barr you
want to be liked again shut the [__] up
about the politics and go be funny and
people will forgive you or just go live
on your farm in Hawaii right rich mother
I mean you can you can be funny if you
don't lean on oh you can use Politics as
a way to make fun of something
but if you're using politics to attack a
group that's the biggest problem with a
lot of these
comedians right that are like oh you
don't get my joke it's like no you
literally just laughed at millions of
people dying because of a virus that
you've said it was a hoax right you
literally are calling people idiots
because they decided to get a vaccine
right you're calling people idiots
because they prefer they prefer a
certain pronoun right a lot of dumb
reasons why you're making fun you're
attacking people and here's the thing I
think the biggest problem with comedians
on that are that are Republicans or
conservatives or whatever you want to
call them is that they constantly punch
down as a comedian you never want to
punch down you always punch up you
always go for the rich you always go for
that right power you always go for the
people
that would normally be against the
common man you can all rally around and
say our position is unfortunate and
unfair because they are in control
because they are the ones who are
telling us that we have to do it this
way or taking away our rights or
whatever it might be but when you punch
down on people right on a certain group
a marginalized Community right whether
you're trans Hispanic black Asian
whatever it might be
that's not funny it's just making fun of
someone and then what ends up happening
is you become a bully and people don't
laugh at you and then you get all butt
hurt because your jokes were really just
a hateful attack on a group that
couldn't defend themselves when you're
in your whatever group of people that
you're telling the jokes to and that's
the problem with conservatives or
Republicans or Maga that say that we're
a comedian I'm a comedian you just don't
get my jokes and it's like no it's just
that the joke wasn't joking and you were
attacking someone they're not that's
what it is
a lot of people in the uh YouTube chat
KIRO is saying I'm a fan of Jon Stewart
and that's a perfect example of someone
who doesn't punch down Jon Stewart does
not punch down he always punches up
that's why Jon Stewart not only has done
great comedies life but has transcended
into Political activism
um because he punched up so much that he
can use his voice and his platform to
punch up to people who are [__] Liars
cheats and stealers in the Congress and
then the Senate and he did so to get uh
to get the the back Act passed last
summer and pushed these [__] to
help veterans which he did the same
thing for the 911 First Responders so
but unlike this [__] has never
done a goddamn thing in his life but
tweet stupid [__] that he thinks is
funny here's another example of they
think it's funny when it's not funny I I
love that this is why he's trending by
the way because this this is this why
he's trending because of this tweet I'm
pretty sure like when I looked at all
the tweets I'm sure there's like other I
saw a clip of him at CPAC talking to
match slap I don't know if that's why
but I'm pretty sure what the last two
was Matt Slap trying to molest him while
they were doing it he was trying to cop
a feel on stage right I I figured that
and he's like I could do that I didn't
do that I mean they are Republicans
um here is Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan tweening this morning on
Valentine's Day here's the [__] he's
worried about here's the [__] he's
worried about shelter gas and food
prices up mysterious objects being shot
down Border in complete crisis military
not hitting recruiting goals train
derailment disaster in Ohio but at least
Joe Biden's got your pronouns right it's
hilarious who no one you are the only
[__] that give a [__] about
pronouns you are the only [__]
to give a [__] about pronouns none of us
on the left give a [__] about pronouns
because here's the thing we we
understand that hey I got mine you got
yours you call me by mine I'll call you
by yours no big [__] deal mind your
own [__] business Jim Jordan here's
here's the truth of the matter here's
the truth the matter gas not up food
prices uh eggs going back down uh
shelter real estate is leveled out to be
quite honest and the Market's getting
lower uh mysterious objects being shot
down we don't know what the [__] they
are and and they're distracting with
these balloon attics are distracting you
um the border is in complete crisis Jim
Jordan you [__] were elected to
fix this in the house where's your bill
where's
where's your border Bill [__]
today we're gonna you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go to the [__]
border I live close enough I can go to
the [__] border I will show you that
this border is not [__] in crisis I'm
gonna do that for you folks I'm gonna
drive down there and we'll do a show
from the [__] border and I'll let you
see that the border is not in [__]
crisis well you should do Texas ball is
fill up your truck with cheaper gas
because of President Biden take you a
set of balloons with helium balloons
down down to the border and set those
[__] free
um to uh display to Jim Jordan the other
one here is military not hitting
recruiting goals the reason why is
because you [__] boneheads made such
a big deal out of [__] mandatory
vaccines and that's the reason why you
say military aren't hinting their goal
because of mandatory vaccines military
has always always and forever will have
vaccine mandates yeah [__] boneheads
and here's the next one trained
derailment in disaster in Ohio you know
it would be it would be one thing if you
could blame this on one Administration
oh that would be beautiful but it would
be another thing if you could blame it
on Republicans and a republican
Administration for cutting [__] for
cutting funding and being anti-union
anti-worker anti-labor not wanting those
human beings to get their their share of
the GDP when it comes to the [__]
railroads and
we can't we can't forget I mean like on
all of those things for sure but on the
last one I mean obviously the the
Hazardous effects of the train
derailment that it has in terms of the
the vinyl chloride which is toxic
especially when it binds to water
molecules but the other thing here is
you also have an organization the EPA
right the Environmental Protection
Agency
that Republicans try to just completely
gut while they well while Trump was
tried they did yeah so you have a group
that would you complain about this
trained derailment right which we could
we could fight about Union we could talk
about deregulation we could talk about
you know uh because how the narrative
goes is the train company says uh they
go oh or the railway company says oh
actually it's these are the talking
points and they feed it to the
politicians and then the media says okay
those are the talking points but
actually when you go back it's the train
it's the railway it's their fault
they're the ones at fault here but
there's a lot of things that went into
play there was a [__] domino effect
and the EPA now has to go in and has to
you know survey the area and make sure
everything's okay and make sure it's all
safe even though still residents are
afraid that there are toxic chemicals in
the air right because I think Vinyl
chloride has a boiling point of eight
degrees Fahrenheit so basically whenever
this [__] hits the ground it becomes
this uh basically an acid right it comes
becomes um uh I'm blaming on the name
but it basically becomes an acid when it
when it binds the moisture in the air
anyway the point being they watch what
the big puff Cloud was right exactly and
still like it just because it happens
like you're like oh look I can see the
cloud of smoke right now that [__] is
still in the air for the same reason
that we have plastic particles you know
in the air that we breathe every day but
this is something also that Jim Jordan
wants to complain about in his home
[__] State well you know what's funny
about it you know it's funnier than
anything is these [__] clowns running
around be like oh small government we
need less government we need less
government and they're blaming the
government on all their [__] problems
and they're like oh Joe Biden needs to
have bigger government we need bigger
government Joe Baden why don't you why
didn't the government intervene
[__] like get the [__] out of
here with this knife yeah why didn't
Pete bootage just go ahead and and and
and create a whole new law that would
they know Trump Trump's [__] poison
pill in the fast act you know I mean the
Republican poison pill in the fast act
that Trump used to repeal the ECP
braking systems regulations why didn't
Pete mudajets just reach in his ass pull
some legislation out and throw it on the
table and say that's what we're going to
do now like that would have [__]
survived a single test in court because
they are in the administrative Branch
not the [__] legislative branch wait
wait wait wait wait wait remind me
remind me again
Jim Jordan is in which branch the
legislative branch okay I I I thought so
I could be working on ECP working on a
lot of [__] things but he ain't gonna
be working on [__] and the reason why is
because he's absolutely obsessed with
gas stoves and the Republican party is
obsessed with genitalia I've been
talking about this for [__] month for
over a year we've been talking about
their obsession with other people's
genitalia and this clip here proves it
and they're gonna there's gonna be more
more this is [__] disgusting as [__]
it is this is gross as [__] I I forget I
think this is in Arkansas is this what
this is I think yeah and his name is
Senator McKee this [__] scumbag and
he is he is questioning a trans female
doctor she's a doctor I think she's a
medical doctor and she's there to give
her testimony based on uh her medical
experience with transgender people right
not her own genitalia but this guy she
doesn't mention it she doesn't bring it
right this guy is so [__] obsessed
with what what what she's sitting there
between your legs is he this is an
official hearing folks on the record
well let me tell you something there
Missy uh you're really making my little
Woody stand up and it's uh it's
bothering me because from what I
understand do you have a penis because
because if you have a penis and I have
an erection and I'm gay and we can't
have that
that's exactly that's exactly why he
says this it's because he's sitting
there and he's so [__] confused he's
so confused about his sexuality and that
and about his [__] rapey ass Vibes
where he he looks at a woman and thinks
I want to have sex with her that he's
wondering oh my God does she have a dick
what would happen would it make me gay
if I think she's attractive that's
literally what he's thinking Texas or
the fact that he's like wait do you have
a penis wait is your penis bigger than
mine right
that's a lot of insecurity he could be
jealous as a [__] guarantee
there is so much insecurity and jealousy
from the fact that they have to win
How could somebody How could somebody
look more attractive than me and also
have a you know bigger dick than me and
that's the that's the crazy [__] that's
in their head right well this is the
[__] they're running around thinking
about listen I've said this for a long
time that people these anti-trans people
especially Republicans but more anything
just [__] trumped up white dudes uh
like Elon and the Elon Simpson Trump
simps uh out there that the uh Andrew
Tate simps all these [__] scumbags
out there that that are no-nothings and
they sit in their [__] mom's living
room on their little computer and and
eat Cheetos and and watch anime and
[__] tweet about this [__] because
they're disgusting pieces of garbage
they're terrified that if they ever
found a woman they ever found a woman
that they that loved them and was
attracted to it's Valentine's Day love
them attracted to them wanted to date
them possibly wanted to go home and
actually [__] their fat scummy asses
that that person might just maybe maybe
they'll trick them and they'll have a
dick and they might like it but here is
here is the here is the the [__]
testimony this is [__] wild ass [__]
and I can't tell you how excited I am to
show you this and the reason why is
because I've been telling you this for a
long [__] time that they're obsessed
obsessed with other people's genitalia
watch this that you're a trans woman I
trans female yes sir do you have a penis
foreign
like you know you know if somebody says
oh yes I'm a trans female right you you
know what you like there's no you may or
may not but who gives a [__] what the
[__] joke but but the idea there is
like it doesn't matter yeah whether they
they have a penis or not like but you
know what happened before they became
and identified as a trans female right
like he knows exactly how that works
like well he's not a [__] idiot in
that sense he knows how it works but the
idea that he has to ask the question
because he's like oh man I'm gonna
[__] own these Libs right now it's
like did you own them or did you just
own yourself well this is the best
perverted [__] [__] this is
[__] dick wanting [__] well
here's the thing I mean that's what
that's all about is hey you look really
good do you got some D for me baby I
mean
I'm Easter well
well I always seem to get the best free
Springs and this freeze frame of her
face like whoa do you want to suck my I
mean this whoa whoa whoa if you want to
do that you're gonna have to ask me
later like in private you know this is
not the place this is
not what she's thinking well I know that
I'm just saying in the freeze frame it
seems that face because that may be what
he's coming I don't know that phase to
me says stranger danger right stranger
danger Republican danger Republican
danger okay so it's really gross when he
asks this question and there a response
from the from her and the people
watching in complete disgust that this
guy would even [__] the first
question he asked is about her genitalia
but watch her follow up and watch how he
knows he stepped on his own dick here
this is hilarious
[Music]
oh
that's horrible you're the one you're
the one that brought that into the
discussion you're the one that never
said anything about genitalia she's like
I didn't say anything about it because
you are the one his logic is like you
brought that into discussion by bringing
yourself into this room and it's like no
dude as soon as she walked into the room
you were like whoa hello yeah and then
you found out she was the witness and
like well wait a second wait a second
she's the witness I was just about to
imagine myself having sex with her
that's what this scumbag is this [__]
McKee and I challenge you you
[__] come on this show and I'll
[__] say it to your face you are
disgusting vile rapey [__] is
what you are and that is why that is why
you are so terrified that you are
attracted to a woman who may or may not
have a penis because it you just can't
fathom you just can't fathom the thought
that you have these weird little
butterflies these little weird little
feelings inside of you you insecure
little piece of [__] you [__] ass [__]
McKee I'm calling him out right now
[__] ass [__] McKee let's let's let's
wrap it up because his response again
you can tell it he he stepped on his own
dick here which is not physically
possible by the way because it's so
small
I don't know what my rights already
please treat me as such
she totally owns him of course well
that's just how it goes in this day and
age when you get all these people you
know and this this is of their own fault
this is of their own fault because
they're obsessed with this issue they
obsess over other people's genitalia if
they would just shut the [__] up and
leave people alone and mind their own
[__] business they would not put
themselves in these situations and
they're going to be more and more of
these situations where they do these
disgusting vile things on camera in
front of microphones and make themselves
look like total fools in front of the
American people because the American
people do not give up [__] what you want
to identify as who you want to love who
you want to have who you want to marry
who you want to be they don't give a
[__] they just want to mind their own
[__] business and have you mind
your own [__] business too
Republicans talk leave me the [__] alone
and stay out of my business liberals
live leave me the [__] alone and stay
out of my business that's it that's a
good one I like that Republicans talk it
and liberals live it I'm talking about
all talk no action
um Elon Musk tweeted uh yesterday he
said what are the top requests for
Twitter features and Bug fixes I said
ousting you as CEO like that did you
guys was your feed yesterday full of his
tweets yes it was just like that I had
like maybe three tweets between and it
was all stupid [__] memes his stupid
[__]
I mean I'm sure I could block him I can
I'll see if I can block him right now
but I also feel like
I've blocked other people because I'm
like you're an idiot I don't want to see
you on my timeline and then I've gone
and just seen them in the trending
section and I go how does this even work
you're breaking the [__] and forcing
people to see your your dumb shows that
I can block him I don't know I don't
want to block him because I want to be
able to see him so I can [__] mouth
him that's that's what I want to see him
that's that's the only reason why you
know that that was my hesitation too was
you know I've got to follow this [__]
because of what I do but it turned out
that I got some repugnant [__] he said I
said the [__] at that [__] I'm blocking
him I blocked him and then uh turns out
that if he says something stupid enough
that it shows up in my timeline anyways
as pictures of what he said so yeah
you're gonna know the the most repugnant
[__] he says anyways is that is that the
um is that the take on it uh let's see
what else what else do we have oh hey
just an FYI you were wondering why Jim
Jordan was trending it's because the
inflation numbers came out and they are
oh wait a second what are they what are
they are they horrible or Jim Jordan no
they're great
looking for 6.2 they got 6.4 uh Jim
Jordan is disappointed that the American
economy is doing well he's really
disappointed that the American economy
is doing he's disappointed that the
American people are coming back from a
pandemic and the economy strong and it's
roaring along he's really pissed off
about this stuff folks yeah he's upset
that you're having I mean that's why
that's why Marjorie Taylor green is
walking around the capitol with the
balloon I mean she she [__] face
planted her first time back on the
committee right she got the five billion
dollars for one single elementary school
then she went on to berade Joel Roth and
other people for the Twitter files only
got smashed that the Twitter files hit
them right back in the face like a
swinging door right and in that same
week right it was like oh we've got the
Chinese balloon the Spy balloon that's
out there and then she and it's all a
distraction right that's the whole point
of that today's episode is distraction
it is they find good news Biden does
something good he acts the way that uh
you know if you compare against Trump he
does the the complete opposite the thing
that he should have done in Trump never
did but Republicans want a [__] and
moan Marco Rubio found you know Cod just
totally just ghost face on camera when
he's told told that three balloons come
into the airspace when Margaret Taylor
green gets [__] railed and made fun
of and mocked she has to carry on a
balloon to distract then she has to
complain about how bad her job is
the petty Eddie outfit oh yeah totally
and then Jim Jordan has to tweet about
how bad the economy is doing and gas
prices and this is up and that's down
and this is bad and this is all when
when you look at the actual facts you
find oh job numbers are 500 000 plus
they were created as opposed to 180 so
that they thought it was going to be
inflation isn't as bad as people thought
it was going to be you find that uh you
know egg prices are going down when they
said they were going up all of these
things you know
that happens from the Republicans and
yes they constantly do it
do they need a talking point and every
time they try to make something up that
is refuted debunked and proven to be
completely false by the facts because
Democrats actually did deliver they get
all whiny and complain and cry about it
and then they try to use the government
to say hey socialism should protect
private news networks like Newsmax wait
wait they're weaponizing the government
don't they know that there's a committee
that is that is investigating that I
mean look there's a community in the
house
the government
do not point it back at yourself
don't point the [__] weapon at your
side well you know this is this
corporate media does the same [__] too
it's talking about what Gabe was talking
about New York Times response to the
great inflation numbers was well the
numbers look good but here's why that's
a problem right here
Democrats well here's the thing is that
uh not uh some more news this morning is
another Democrat is getting into the
into a race we saw several get into the
senate race in Colorado uh we watch
Lucas Koontz get into the senate race in
Missouri against Josh Hawley and now we
have Adam Frisk um he's getting into the
Congressional race again against uh
Lauren bobert which he only lost by just
over 500 votes yeah um in that District
so um which is more good news that a guy
that damn near beat her is going to run
against her again and hopefully stomp
her uh into a mud hole into that into
that District in Colorado and she sure
what's but the key is folks is that
these Democrats are getting into the
race and what we have to do is form a
national narrative and National
messaging is what we have to do and we
can't stay distracted and one of the
things that they're trying to distract
us with is the balloons the media all
the Medias can't stop talking about the
[__] balloons they keep asking the
administration they ask the [__] DOD
they had balloons what are these UFOs
are they aliens are they balloons are
they spot listen they haven't recovered
them yet when they recover them they'll
give you a report and then you can
[__] report on it you [__]
balloonitix they can't stop talking
about [__] in the sky that they're that
now they're looking for because of this
spy balloon now they're finding [__]
that they didn't find before it's not
complicated this [__] is not complicated
to know and once they figure out what
the [__] they are they'll tell you
they'll tell you what they are it's not
it's not it's not rocket surgery okay
and I was [__] refused to let the
Republicans create this goddamn
narrative like you saw on the Jim Jordan
tweet you put up and they're letting
China spy on us [__] no let me tell you
the goddamn truth right now today we are
spying on [__] China we are spying on
China right now today and they are
spying on us we both have [__]
satellites watching what's going on we
[__] spy on each other you know who
else we spy on Israel you know who spies
on us Israel wait you're [__] life no
no you can't that's not you you're
speaking I refuse
to live stop talking about facts you're
gonna hurt their [__] feelings if you
keep talking I refuse to allow a stupid
[__] narrative to live it has nothing
to do with that we spy on each other
every [__] Nation on Earth that has
the capability is spying on somebody so
that he they can know what the [__] is
happening yes people spy on us you know
what's gonna really hurt the media's
feelings in the next oh I know three
months when they're doing reports
they're like oh well uh the Spy balloon
and we actually collected more
information than it put out oh oh and
all those other [__] that they shot down
they were just [__] weather balloons
and a private experiments that people
were doing and it's it was nothing it
was just they were it's really [__]
dumb it's really I mean there's a part
of me there's a part of me that's like
oh man if only this was the moment in
which aliens decided for I mean I can
guarantee the aliens have spied on us
you know and everything they they flip
there are aliens yeah
um they're probably aliens I mean but
that's why they're not coming here right
now they're like we don't wanna we don't
want this [__] dumpster fire yeah
[__] that but in the event that they did
come down and we just shot them down and
it's like well now we did just bring an
alien invasion War upon ourselves
because we didn't we didn't say hey
greetings it was just like you and we
just shot them down well you know what's
funny is they always it's always like
the Sci-Fi the Sci-Fi stories that
aliens come and they destroy our planet
uh yeah it destroys us and and
Aliens we deserve it yeah well but
that's the motive they're flying by
they're like if we just wait a little
while they're gonna be gone anyways like
they won't be able to take their plant
with no resistance because they're going
to kill themselves off that planet
that's right the planet is going to
cease to exist them because we're not
destroying our planet we're just
destroying our ability to live here and
Mother Nature's like look [__] if you
don't get your [__] into shape I'm gonna
make it to where you can't stay in the
house and I'm gonna I'm gonna get rid of
you [__] shake off the fleas as
George Garland said uh before we go I
want to get some Shameless plugs here
first off we got a brand new design in
the merch store go to store.d Tony
michaels.com that's
stored.dtonymichaels.com Surf's Up
[__] shirts are there we're
gonna have several different designs
coming we're going to have a p a b [__]
ass [__] 45 I think we're gonna do a
couple different designs of that one and
I think we might do another surf set
[__] or to actually say
[__] instead of mfers we just
wanted to keep this one to where people
could could um look at it there we're
Texas Palmdale
he must have been having trouble I was
gonna let him give a Shameless plug I
wouldn't kick anymore I don't know uh
everyone if you do oh there he's back
he's back I was I was gonna say uh give
us give us a Shameless plug I got all
your links down below to your YouTube
channel so give us a Shameless plug here
yeah go to realtexaspaul.com all the
information you need the links to all my
shows everything is there
realtexaspaul.com got my website up and
running Tony
I'm telling you Tech genius over here no
no I have to tell you Mrs Texas Paul did
it all man she is she is
and thank Miss Texas Paul in the chat
she's there probably because Texas ball
couldn't do anything without her I would
imagine
um I think I'm safe saying that on
Valentine's Day am I safe saying that
here's your safe saying that on the
other oh yeah on any day probably right
you couldn't manage that you couldn't
manage without her you couldn't manage
it look you know I tell the truth and
every relationship you got a winner and
a loser you do it's never two people of
the same capabilities and whatnot to get
together you've always got somebody that
and I I won I won are you she is way
smarter way more successful way more
everything than I am and I just [__]
lucked up I did well you know sometimes
some of us get lucky sometimes we do or
some of us know how to lay pipe oh Jesus
Christ
wait uh uh do you do you have a penis do
you have a Pete Jesus Christ okay uh
Gabe Sanchez I'm not gonna ask you that
question but um go ahead and give a give
a Shameless frog and try not to put any
dick jokes in it or yeah yeah whichever
one you want no no laying pipe right now
right so uh yeah you can you can check
me out on Twitter uh I am Gabe Sanchez
uh I just launched my patreon for the
what was that show is a bunch of
exclusive content that I'll be putting
out there uh patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez uh exclusive Clips behind the
scenes stuff q and A's you name it go
there patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or
you can go to what was thatshow.com
it'll redirect you
um and you can get all the goodies so
so uh someone's sending me a private
message saying TMI Tuesday
I apologize it's Valentine in the last
30 minutes of the show it becomes TMI
Tuesday yeah tmit maybe we should uh
continue that uh going forward but here
uh here's here's uh what I want to tell
you I appreciate uh everyone being here
on Valentine's Day I don't really think
it's a holiday it's more of a commercial
line so they can sell [__] candy and
and Roses but you know whatever you
whatever floats your boat if you want to
go out and have a good meal or if you
want to stay at home and cook for your
your significant other or if you don't
have a significant other say [__] it and
make a microwave me on sit in front of
the TV and watch Netflix I don't give a
[__] what you do be safe be safe out
there have a great Valentine's Day uh
tell the people that you love not just
your your singing man but tell the
people you love around you that you love
them that's the most important thing is
to show love and be intolerant of
intolerance because we can't not let
them control the narrative that is the
most important thing in our democracy
because we want to keep it so also one
more Shameless plug for the Surf's Up
[__] shirts I love that shirt
or that the Tony michaels.com store not
the tonymichaels.com it's at the very
bottom I was going to put that's a
badass shirt you know what I want them
to have to go to the bottom to see the
rest of the stuff if they haven't seen
it so go to
store.dtonymichaels.com find the Surf's
Up [__] t-shirts there and make
sure to come back here tomorrow because
I think we got a few more designs that
we're working on and I think we'll drop
one more this week maybe a couple next
week so you guys can decide what merch
you want
um you know for the spring I just put a
t-shirt up we'll put hoodies and long
sleeves shirts and I think we'll be in
doing some hats and some other merch
some stickers
um so be watching for those but the
t-shirts the Surf's Up [__]
teeth it shirts up [__]
t-shirts are up right now in the store
don't forget to come back tomorrow same
time same place noon Eastern 11 Central
nine Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch live also simulcasting from the
minus touch Facebook page do not forget
to subscribe to the YouTube channel
you're going to want to vote for
bonehead of the week where you go to the
community tab on Thursdays that's that's
that's later on in the week but make
sure to also follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod so you can vote there
and download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google leave us a great
review while you're there same time
same place tomorrow go get your shirt
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
them
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon